hey everyone and welcome to my tutorial
on how to make a paper rocket ship
making the rocket ship will be the
trickiest origami model that I have
taught you how to make so far but I will
go through each step and every fold in
detail and try to simplify things as
best I can
there are a lot of similar folds
involved in making the paper balloon and
also the origami crane that you will
also see when making the paper rocket
ship so if you don't know how to already
make the balloon and the crane I highly
recommend that you watch my tutorials on
how to do those first before trying to
make the rocket ship making the rocket
ship requires that we have a square
piece of paper so if you're using a
piece of printer paper what you do is
you take this corner and you fold it
until this edge is lined up make a
crease and then you're going to cut off
the excess paper so now you should have
a piece of square paper that has a
diagonal fold in it now that we have a
square piece of paper with the diagonal
fold going this way we're going to take
this corner and fold the paper in half
until it meets this corner and then we
make a crease then you open up the paper
again and we're going to fold it in half
going this way this time and then you
make another crease now if you open up
the paper you should see an X and also a
horizontal fold as well fold the paper
in half on that horizontal fold then
what we do is we lift up this first
sheet and we're going to tuck this
corner in all the way down in the middle
just like that so lift it up and you
tuck this corner in like that and then
you make a crease do the same for the
left side
so you should have something that looks
just like this then what we're going to
do is we're going to fold each of these
flaps all the way up until the tip of
the flap meets the top of this triangle
do the same for the remaining three
flaps flip it over now you should have
something that looks just like this you
might recognize this from when we made
the paper balloon now what we're going
to do is something called a squash fold
what we do is we take these flaps and we
open up the middle of it which is sort
of like a pocket and if you open it up
you'll see that this corner wants to go
down and what you do is you push it down
until this corner meets the bottom of
this diamond so you take the flap open
it up all the way and then you push down
until this corner meets here and then
what you do is you make two creases one
here and one here so now you should have
something that looks just like this and
you want to do that for the remaining
three flaps
now we're going to do something that's
known as the pedal fold which you may
remember from my crane tutorial when we
were making the wings of the bird what
we need to do is we need to take each of
these corners here and we're going to
fold it so that this edge is on this
line that you see here this diagonal
line so we take it and we fold it until
it's on that line
so you should have something that looks
like that and you want to do that for
both sides so we have three more to go
now what we have to do is we have to
unfold these corners which we just fold
it in all right so these folds and
creases which we just made were to make
the petal fold a little bit easier what
you want to do now is you want to lift
up this corner here and you want to kind
of push it up and pull it until these
corners start to tuck in towards the
center so you lift it up and you'll see
that these corner pieces will start to
tuck in towards the center and what you
want to do is you want to just flatten
it out so you just tuck them in and then
you're just going to flatten the whole
thing out and you want to do that for
the remaining three so let's go ahead
and do that
now what we're going to do is we're just
going to fold these petal structures in
half so fold it down and do that for the
remaining three all right so this next
fold that I'm going to show you is not
tricky but you want to watch carefully
as I do it to make sure you're doing it
correctly if these petals are kind of
sticking out what you do is just put
your thumb at the bottom here to hold
them down then you're going to open
these two flaps on the right and what we
want to do is we want to take this
vertical edge this edge right here and
we're going to fold it backwards until
it meets this middle line here that
separates these two flaps so we want to
take this and we're going to fold it
backwards just like that until it gets
right into the center and then we're
going to just squish it down and flatten
it so you should have something that
looks just like this and then you want
to do that for the remaining three flaps
so now you should have something that
looks just like this now what we're
going to do is we're going to take the
tips of these petals and we're kind of
just going to let them swing outwards so
we're just going to swing it open and as
you'll see a little hood is formed what
you want to do with that hood is you
just want to squash it so just push
right down on it just like that then
we're going to do it for the remaining
three so open this let it swing open and
then you just push down on that hood
flip it over and do the same thing okay
so now what you want to do is you want
to take this little corner on the bottom
here and you want to tuck it up inside
of the rocket as far up as it will go
just like that and then you want to
flatten it and you want to do that for
the other side also so now you should
have something that looks just like this
okay so if you take a look at the nearly
completed rocket you can see it's kind
of flattened out so that these two legs
are next to each other and these two
legs are next to each other what you
want to do is you just want to open it
up and you want to flatten it the other
way so that these top two are next to
each other and the bottom two are next
to each other and then you want to
flatten it out and make a good crease
that way so now you should have a model
that looks like this okay so if you look
at the model you'll see what looks like
four little kites on the bottom here
what you want to do is you want to take
the corner of this kite shape and you
want to fold it in half going this way
so you want to take it and you want to
push down on it when you do that you'll
see that this edge here is kind of
dragged along with it it's holding it
back so what you want to do you want to
fold it and you want to push straight
down on that edge just like that and
flatten everything out and you want to
do that for the remaining three
alright guys we just have two folds left
and they're really easy all you have to
do is just turn the rocket over and just
open it up a little bit and just like
before when we tuck these corners in we
just want to tuck these in also so just
fold it down inside of the rocket and
then do the same for the other side and
if you hold it like this you'll see that
you have now completed your paper rocket
ship thanks a lot for watching my
tutorial for how to make the paper
rocket ship I know it was tricky so be
sure to go back and re-watch some parts
which might have given you trouble just
to make sure you're making the correct
folds if you haven't already seen my
tutorial for how to make the paper crane
the balloon and also the ninja star you
can check them out by going to my
channel videos by clicking on my name to
the right and as always be sure to
comment rate and subscribe for
notification of my future videos